the YouTube red series ultimate
expedition is a ten episode series that
has a bunch of celebrities trying to
scale the nearly 20,000 foot mount tow
Clara who in Peru and one of those
contestants sitting to my right right
here former UFC light heavyweight
champion Chuck Liddell good to see you
sir good to see you
you made it huh I'm here that's not a
spoiler alert right that you made it
through the episodes we made it through
the episodes I'm like I can't let you
know what you got have to watch the show
okay sure did
right but what would that you know how
would this rank in terms of degrees of
difficulty of things that you've
entertained in your your career you're
lying Chuck altitude is is an
interesting thing I've never been that
high before and I was also coming off of
I was an I had an injury and I was you
know rehabbing it and we first got the
call for the show I thought it started
to shoot in at the end October uh-huh
I said yeah sure that's fine about three
months to train for and I'm ready to go
I'll be ready to go when it comes around
and talking my manager and she said no
no it's in two weeks I'm like oh well
yeah oh well why not let's do it it's a
good way to get back in shape so so you
did it so I did it yeah and used you you
made it through and what did you learn
about yourself you know did you learn
anything about yourself because normally
people who go through an experience like
this you know discover something yeah
the biggest thing for me is that that I
don't want to take time off anymore you
know I retired and I was kind of lost
for a little while and didn't know what
really know what I really wanted to do I
was having a great time with my family
and do do a lot of things but it was you
know I didn't have that drive I didn't
have anything I need you need goals you
need to be working towards something and
you know for me that's that way it was a
wake-up call and a kick in the bud to
get back in shape and and start working
for things but what are you these are
something you could tell me what you're
working toward right now well I'm
working towards a lot of things I got
something signed coming up pretty big
pretty soon
but I can't let you know that yet but
it's coming
you're full of spoiler alerts man
there's a ton of spoiler alerts right
now Chuck I'm getting a whole the whole
whole situation that's look I'm glad
that you you discovered that cuz you
know I've been around a bunch of retired
athletes and certainly the the guys who
I deal with the most or are NFL players
who sometimes they're eight 25 26 trying
to figure out what to do I've been
around Hall of Famers who are 31 32
sometimes when they retire and and they
don't know what's coming next
you know it's really a tough thing you
know you go through your whole life with
this goal you always have I always had
the next game the next fight the next
something for 30 years you know growing
up playing football play wrestling
fighting always had that thing out there
and all of a sudden you don't have to do
anything you know it's it's a freedom
but then it's kind of like there's
nothing to drive you it's kind of you
and I was trying to do a lot of
different things but it just wasn't that
one thing that kept me under control and
for me that's that's not a good thing
and you know I've always talked about
mental toughness it's one of those
things that can start it started for me
he started slipping away I thought
because I always said it I've always
said it's a mental toughness is an
everyday thing it's you you can't just
turn on and turn off when you want to
hmm
you have to always do it and so I was
going for a run up a hill with fur might
not supposed to run but they started
running as we started racing and it was
getting I was flagging a little bit but
I know I was chasing them and I actually
went through my mind should I stop which
has never happened to me you know I
that's not something that's normal for
me I don't my brain just goes you can't
stop you have to beat him right so if I
eat he might be able to beat me but he's
gonna have to beat me when I fall down
and I can't go anymore
is my normal reaction but after it's
having that time off and kind of think
oh I don't have to go work out I don't
have to go to gym I don't have to do
this and after that it made a lot easier
to actually have that crossed my mind
now I made the right decision and I
actually won the race up the hill okay
but I couldn't go on anymore but but
still it the fact that across my mind
really bothered me so
interesting Chuck Liddell here on the
Rich Eisen show what do you miss most
about funny I miss everything about
fighting I mean I I miss fight week I
miss cutting weight I miss I miss
everything I mean I love fighting I got
paid a lot of money too I love for a
living so you know I can't can't say
there's anything that I don't miss so is
there a party that may want to even
entertain the idea of coming back I've
entertained it I'm entertaining it I
mean a couple people in running their
mouths a lot but so you know I you know
they put they bring enough money they
offer me enough money oh I'm more than
happy to shut those nose well it's
interesting that you would say that
because we had a guest on on Tuesday
show is running his mouth because well I
brought your name up it's not like he
didn't but here's what Chael Sonnen had
to say he was here yesterday I've
noticed you and Chuck Liddell have kind
of gone back and forth on social media
would you like to leave him a note
I could dictate it no I will tell you
this Chuck seems to be a very nice guy
he's got a good reputation I hear he
treats people well he's got a walk
around town with a haircut that looks
like he lost a bet and I wish Chuck the
best should I write that down and you
can I don't know if he could read it
it's not dictating it for him but just
the fact that you'd have to read it to
him and then and then explain it beyond
that but hmm no I don't have any
business with Chuck he had flirted with
the idea that he was going to come back
and so he was in my crosshairs but but
he's not coming back okay a couple days
what one is he he doesn't need he kind
of likes to talk a lot of trash without
having actual facts hmm I think he
actually said he's not worried about
what right or wrong facts I mean he said
I was offered fights and turned him down
I think was one of his his big ones
which is definitely not true no one's
ever offered me a fight with him and you
know I he's he's good running his mouth
that's what he got good at because he's
a boring fighter he's a lame prey he's
not not interesting to watch he's not
fun to watch unless the other guy's
making it fun but so yeah he's like I
said before he'd been easy come back for
me if ever if they want to give me that
one that one's I mean it's like I mean
he's got it he's got pillows for hands
so it's all good okay
so would you
you take a fight against him I don't
yeah there won't pay enough yeah what
about going into a boxing ring would you
ever do something like that since that
since that seems to be the this
switching everything up you know back to
that moments the world in back in the
day we were talking with Holyfield's
guys about doing a kickboxing match no
kidding
and meeting in the middle of doing
kickboxing and actually I was just
talking to bas Rutten and and he said
they were talking to him at the same
time right about it but you know that
would be interesting for me I mean I
with some of these I mean if they paid
enough money and I'm a fighter man I'll
box I'm gonna unbox with you two but you
know I I would like I mean I'd like it
to be kickboxing so I have a lot better
shot at winning horse so cuz that that's
part of the thing that was going down
with Mayweather and McGregor to is it
just seemed to be like such apples and
oranges you know yeah that was a circus
play it's all right it's great the thing
is that people always comparing boxing
striking with MMA striking they're two
different things
I mean you can't stand in the same
stance you can't the timing is different
everything is different moving from
boxing to kickboxing and then moving
kickboxing to MMA is even more different
so I mean if you stand in a boxing
stance against me and a kickboxing match
you have about around maybe around and a
half to knock me out after that you're
not gonna be able to put enough pressure
on your front leg to knock me out so I
mean it's just it's apples and oranges
the strike it you can't strike the same
way you do there's a lot of similarities
but you can't strike the same way you do
in boxing as you do anything check
littell here on the Rich Eisen show how
long do you think may rather would have
lasted in an octagon with not long ago I
used to tell him I have when he was back
in the day when he was talking trash to
me I just don't have a 135 pound my
house that you wouldn't make it on the
first round way so I mean it would it
would be ugly I mean he's gonna take him
down and he won't get up I mean if you
haven't I even a leg kick even if he
could McGregor could leg kick yes it
would be maybe a big trouble for him hmm
which other athletes from other
endeavors because I mean your your
popular guy people have been
for you for quite some time do you think
would have the ability to get to become
a fighter which one do you say that
you've come across not named Jay Glazer
obviously but who else would that be Jay
has problems with conditioning he has a
hard time with that altitude training
it's one of those things he has a big
problem with right um uh you know I'd
like to see Grant get in there I love
watching him play man he's a beast out
there on the field what he's been asked
what would you how would you train Gronk
how would you say that Gronk could could
win something well you know I understand
his his uh his athletic ability give me
a not an athlete sure guys got good
athletic ability and guys look into if
it guy who can take a punch
great hands - yeah I agree give me the
contact fast you know used to contact he
can you know he can take it take a hit
give me a guy I always said give me give
me an athlete and I can teach him how to
fly
is he too tall though I mean if I didn't
know okay height is great okay how to
use it use your length use your distance
I've got LeBron then LeBrons a great
athlete - always that but it takes a
long time to teach the stuff that we do
so it's not it's not that easy to
transfer from one sport to the other but
now I only I can teach I feel like I can
teach anybody anybody that's a great
athlete and can take a punch
yeah I can teach a mattify okay well
look I look forward to seeing Altima
expedition on YouTube read again
premieres today so you can get to your
computer right now and check that out or
all the apps that can just pop it right
there on your television and I look
forward to hearing what your news is
that you're saying you know it's coming
authority here and all that I I
appreciate it thanks for coming on come
back come back anytime thanks for having
me bet that's Chuck Liddell check out
him on Twitter at Chuck Liddell and
check him out on YouTube red series
ultimate expedition today the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience